je veux dire c'est un court répit non
mais c'est au rider
des français sous le choc notre dame de
paris ravagé par les flammes
c'était le 15 avril 2019 il ya tout
juste deux ans en fin d'après-midi vers
18h50 un incendie se déclare sous les
combles de la cathédrale c'est le coeur
de paris non coeur c'est vrai que c'est
un peu notre car elle est aussi très
vite le sinistre prend de l'ampleur
les poutres de la charpente qui date du
xiiie siècle brûle et menace de
s'effondrer
un énorme panache de fumée visible
pratiquement dans tout paris notre dame
est en feu
le monument le plus visité d'europe l'un
des symboles de la capitale française
à périmètre de sécurité est mis en place
les secours affluent par centaines
400 pompiers tentent de maîtriser un
incendie et notre-dame brûle toujours et
à 19h50
une heure après le début du drame
notre dame amputé paris perd l'un de ses
symboles la france un pan de son
histoire
la flèche de la cathédrale construite
par l'architecte viollet le duc au 19e
siècle s'effondre les patients sont
horrifiés certains prix et se
recueillent
d'autres pleurent à l'image de cette
jeune touriste je suis choqué j'étais à
l'intérieur encore ce matin il ya
tellement d'histoires dedans et là ça
juste disparu
de leur côté les pompiers tentent
toujours de maîtriser un incendie
mais la tâche s'avère complexe l'édifice
est immense et passé par les airs
n'aurait fait qu'aggraver la situation
selon cet ancien pompier
on peut absolument pas utiliser un
canadair vous imaginez on est en plein
centre ville
vous êtes au milieu de la cité et que le
poids de l'eau projetée à plusieurs
dizaines de mètres de hauteur aurait
fracassé l'ensemble de la toiture
finalement en fin de soirée les pompiers
parviennent à sauver les deux tours de
notre dame et le 16 avril au petit matin
après quatorze heures de lutte acharnée
le feu est éteint mais les dégâts sont
considérables
voici l'hôtel tel qu'il était auparavant
coeur des célébrations religieuses
il ne reste plus rien à part la croix
miraculeusement intacte la nef autrefois
si rayonnante ressemblent désormais un
sombre couloir
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la cathédrale est toujours
en restauration un chantier colossal qui
devrait prendre fin en avril 2024 veille
des jeux olympiques de paris
[Musique]